brought to you by watchdogs to hack
everything available on consoles
November 15th and on PC November 29 hey
guys this is the 16th of November my
name is Justin you're watching gamespot
news here's the important things that
happened today
first up MIT is developing tech that is
going to enable wireless VR which if
you've ever used VR is something we
sorely sorely need researchers at the
computer science and artificial
intelligence laboratory have developed a
prototype called mov r which can make
any VR headset operate wirelessly it
uses high-frequency radio signals called
millimeter waves that allow for the
untethered transfer of multiple billions
of bits per second MIT professor dina
katabi explained the ability to use a
cordless headset really deepens the
immersive experience of virtual reality
and opens up a range of other
applications the researchers are hopeful
that the tech could expand to a point
where multiple active headsets could be
used inside a single play space without
blocking each other's signals changing
pace little the game awards nominees
have been announced today and here are
the highlights titles up for the overall
game of the Year award include doom
inside overwatch titanfall 2 and
uncharted for a thief's end uncharted 4
picked up eight nominations including
those for performance game direction art
direction and narrative while fire watch
inside and overwatch all had five
nominations each a total of 63 games
were nominated across all categories for
the full list of nominations check out
our story on gamespot be sure to let us
know who you reckon we'll win each of
the award for this year finally Xbox
boss Phil Spencer has discussed the
price of the upcoming project Scorpio
the more powerful Xbox one is slated to
cost more than a $300 xbox one asks that
just how much more is yet to be
announced spencer dhed hold level up
calm Scorpio will be a premium console
it will cost more than s obviously
that's how we're building it we've not
announced the pricing yet but I want to
make sure that the investment we're
putting into the product of Scorpio
meets the demands of the high-end
consumer and that will be a higher price
he also reiterated that Scorpio is
designed to sit alongside the existing
Xbox one and simply caters to a
different kind of customer recently
analyst Michael Pachter told gamingbolt
that it would be suicide for the console
to cost more than four hundred dollars
ps4 pro which launched last week is
priced at four hundred bucks project
scope is set to go on sale in the
holiday season of next year that is
everything I got for you today do head
to game [ __ ] for stories on persona 5
and that'll field one and I will see you
again tomorrow